Australia's known for its dangerous
animals none more so koala learning and
they can more people oh god what is he
doing home hi I'm Anne Jones from ABC
science and today we've got videos
[Music]
just quickly if you like this sort of
video
why don't you tap that subscribe button
so you can see some more let's get into
it the first time people hear koalas in
the wild they generally freak the hell
out now the thing is the reason why it's
low is that low sounds travel much
further in the forest environment the
way that sound waves work is high sounds
are really close together like this and
low sounds have big long waves like that
and travel a long distance so when he's
calling out like that
he's telling everyone in earshot that
he's the bear he's basically advertising
how sexy he's
[Music]
they're so noisy and if this happens
near your house in the middle of the
night it's sort of terrifying and it can
go on for hours this could be a mating
sort of situation what's probably
happened is the male's had a go the
females refused so the male has kicked
her out of the tree and what's really
interesting about the Koala mating
situation is that it is very
antagonistic it isn't about you know the
post-coital afterglow they do a lot of
yelling a lot of screaming and a lot of
the time it isn't successful oh there's
two of them bit of beef oh this is just
like all animals but you know because
they're so cute it's sort of shocking
how vicious they can get probably two
males right the roles
all right so it's probable that this is
a territorial fight right and there are
a couple of options with what could
exactly be happening it could be the
border between two territories of male a
and male B the second could be that one
is an older Koala and one is a younger
koala and that young one is being
evicted from its parents territory and
the third could be it always comes back
to sex they're going to want to do the
Koala boogie and there's a female nearby
let's go play me another one and I'm
gonna try to get the little guy out of
my cart but he just does not want it
comes oh I guess they come out of my car
please
what happened what do we move for mate
I'm not gonna hurt you come on uh what
is a koala doing in that guy's car hey
buddy gonna go out the other side now
not are you gorgeous okay I'm not trying
to hurt you
don't bite me god that is so dangerous
see those claws and you can actually see
the front paws there there's sort of
like two thumbs and three fingers so
it's sort of almost like the live long
and prosper symbol but the other way
around and that helps them grip onto
trees oh god what is he doing don't do
that oh it's really scary the best thing
to do I think would be open up all the
doors to give it all the options to
escape and like just stay on one door
and make big movements I'd also probably
have my dog tied up what happened to you
- might get on you might thanks for all
the damage to my car so the the Koala is
obviously in distress because it's
approaching humans I mean it's a
beautiful beautiful thing to do now I've
read that the recommendation is not to
use a water bottle and is not to have it
so that the Koala is actually tipping
its head back like that because you can
actually drown the Koala so the best
thing to do is to put out a bowl of
water and let the Koala come to that
beautiful lunch
[Music]
how is that a real animal look at that
little Bobby biggest risk factor for
koalas in Australia is habitat
degradation and that includes where
their habitat is dissected by roads like
this if you see a koala in the wild and
especially if it's on the ground give it
space
now if the koala approaches you safe to
say there's probably something going on
that isn't quite right that's where I'd
be thinking about calling in an expert
[Music]
yeah okay look I think we can't even
pretend that koalas are deadly the only
thing they're gonna do is kill us with
that cuteness we've heard from so many
of you that you want cassowaries the
two-legged killer well we want to look
at cassowaries too but we need the
videos so if you've got one where you
almost get killed by a cassowary why
don't you send it to us here at ABC
science